and joining us now here in studio is the
secretary of homeland security alejandro
mayorkas welcome back sir to fox news
sunday thank you very much for having me
i want to start with those 30 000
haitian migrants who came across the
border into del rio texas since
september 9th as you say
you say that 12 400 will have their
cases heard by an immigration judge and
another 5 000 are being processed by
your department mr secretary of those
seventeen thousand four hundred
how many have been released into the u.s
and how many more potentially could be
released into the u.s so chris um uh
about three 000 are actually in
detention
and we make those detention
determinations in the best interest of
the american public others are in
immigration court proceedings they are
monitored by us we impose conditions
upon them so we
keep in touch with them and ensure their
appearance in court as the law requires
but to answer my question directly of
the seventeen thousand four hundred
that weren't deported back or didn't
return on their own to mexico how many
of them either
well first how many have been released
into the u.s uh they're released on
conditions and approximately i think
it's about ten thousand or so twelve 000
have been released yes and of the five
thousand that are still in process
we will make determinations whether they
will be uh returned
uh to uh haiti uh based on our public
health and public interest
authorities
so are we talking about a total of 12
000 or could it be even higher it could
it could be even higher the number that
a return could be even higher what we do
is we follow the law as congress has
passed it but let's drill down on more
than 12 000 migrants who
you say that you're going to keep
surveillance over but they are being
released
into this country
chris that's what the law requires
if in fact someone is not expelled under
the public health authority of the
centers for disease control then they
are placed in immigration enforcement
proceedings they have an opportunity
to make their claim for relief to a
judge as the law requires but i
understand all of that but let's talk
about what's going to happen to those 12
000 removal proceedings including asylum
cases can take anywhere from six months
to several years and 44 according to the
department of justice 44 of those who
are released into custody or from
custody miss
their court hearings
just as a matter of reality won't many
of those thousands of people end up
settling here in the united states some
of them permanently chris we have
enforcement guidelines in place that
provide that individuals who are recent
border crossers
who do not uh show up for their hearings
are enforcement priorities and will be
removed and that is one of our do you
remove all of them or do some of them
disappear into the country well we it is
uh our intention to remove them that is
what our policies are and we deploy our
enforcement resources according to
certain priorities to ensure the safety
and security of the american people but
sir there are more than 11 million
people in this country illegally clearly
despite your best efforts
millions of people end up in this
country and don't just disappear
chris 11 million people in this country
without lawful presence is a compelling
reason why there is unanimity about the
fact that our immigration system is
broken
and legislative reform is needed
okay according to internal documents
your department is now tracking
a lot more people
including haitians who were on their way
up from south america central america to
cross the border into this country i
want to put up the numbers 20 000
haitians in colombia 3 000 in peru and
1500 in panama
in may the byte administration extended
temporary protected status for the 150
000 haitians already living in the new
u.s and now as you've said you've
released another more than 12 000
into the country our next guest texas
governor abbott traveled to del rio to
the site of that bridge and the
15 000 people huddled under the bridge
this week and here's what he had to say
take a look
when you have an administration that has
abandoned any pretense
of securing the border and securing our
sovereignty
you see the on rush
of people like what we saw
walking across this dam
that is right behind me
hasn't this
administration created a magnet haven't
you given the haitians and
a million more immigrants who you had an
encounter with out since joe biden came
into office haven't you given them a
reason to believe there's a reasonable
chance if they come into this country
they'll end up being released
into the country and have months or
perhaps years to stay here
chris this is nothing new
we've seen this type of irregular
migration many many times
throughout the years i don't know if
governor abbott said the same thing in
2019
uh when there were more than a million
people encountered at the southern
border
it has gotten worse just this is the
statistics of of your own department
show that the flood of people coming
illegally across the border has gotten
worse under the biden administration so
i wouldn't call it a a flood chris if i
if i may but
we have seen large numbers of
individuals
uh encountered at our border making a
claim for asylum for humanitarian relief
which is a
statute which is a law
uh
of the united states that individuals
can make a claim of fear of persecution
by reason of their membership in a
particular social group that's what the
law provides
this
we are certainly seeing a large number
here in this year but in 2019 we saw a
large number in 2014 in 2010 this is
nothing new it spans
many many years
it spans different administrations of
both parties and it speaks to the need
for legislative reform
i want to get to this question about
asylum seekers having to come over in a
minute but i want to talk first because
you say well nothing has changed
you had i mean i think as what
was so dramatic about these last two
weeks is that yes there is a trickle of
people to come across but to see 30 000
people in 17 days come across the border
into one location and be hiding under
that or huddling under that bridge you
say 30 000 people walked across that dam
into del rio in the last 17 days
question why didn't you stop them
oh so
we encounter them
at the border that's where we encounter
them chris and you know what we saw
indeed a large number of people
cross at one particular part of the
border in a short period of time and
what did we do
we surged our resources we surged our
personnel and why didn't you stop them
from coming into the country we um we
did we encountered them uh they gathered
they assembled uh in that one location
in del rio texas and we applied the laws
we applied the public health law under
the cdc's authority and we applied
immigration question is why did you
allow them in the country in the first
place why didn't you build
forgive me a wall or a fence to stop
them from walking in this flood of
people coming across the dam it looks
like a highway that allows them to cross
the rio grande it is this the policy of
this administration we do not agree with
the building of the wall the law
provides that individuals can make a
claim for humanitarian relief that is
actually one of our proudest traditions
of the 30 000 haitians who came across
the border into del rio how many did
your department test for covid so we
have strict covat testing protocols that
we apply across the board we test
isolate and quarantine unaccompanied
children we work with non-profit
organizations to test families those who
are in ice custody are tested isolated
and quarantined those who are expelled
under the title 42 public health
authority are returned
immediately they are not placed in
immigration court proceedings and those
we do not test but because they are
returned immediately but your own
department's
inspector general said that your testing
policy and the failure to test a lot of
people who end up in this country that
you rely on local or state officials and
a lot of people don't get tested has put
communities in this country at risk we
concurred with those recommendations we
made improvements uh that is also
nothing new that is exactly why we have
an independent review
of our operations to see where we can
make uh improvements where we can
strengthen our processes and that is
exactly what we did here couple more
questions i want to get into with you
your department is now investigating
the border patrol for those officers on
horseback who were at the border trying
to keep haitians from coming across the
border here is senator
lindsey graham talking about that
i think the most inhumane thing going on
right now in america is that the men and
women of the border patrol have been
completely abandoned demagogues
scapegoat and treated like dirt by
elected officials in the democratic
party and this administration
i know you've got an investigation going
on so i'm not going to ask you about
what they did
what i am going to ask you is who
ordered those patrol agents on horseback
to go to the border and what were they
supposed to do
chris i'd like to not speak about what
they were supposed to do because that
also touches upon
the investigation that is ongoing
what their policies and training require
and whether or not those individuals
but the horse patrol is something that
the border patrol employs because horses
can traverse they can cover terrain that
might not otherwise be covered
but they weren't there they were on the
border to block the the
haitians from coming across
we use the border patrol the horse
patrol
to assess
the situation and very often to help
people in distress whether these
individual border patrol agents on
horseback
complied with our policies and training
or whether they did not is the subject
of an investigation and that
investigation is independent and the
outcome will be determined by the facts
and nothing more finally you talked
earlier about the fact that allowing
people to come into this country to make
a claim of asylum is the law but in fact
and you know this well sir more than a
month ago the supreme court
overruled the idea that the this
administration had unilaterally decided
to rescind president trump former
president trump's remain in mexico
policy that people had to wait in mexico
while making their claim of asylum they
made that
ruling more than a month ago why have
you failed to comply with the supreme
court's ruling to reinstate remain in
mexico so it is a district court ruling
it's a federal supreme court ruling well
the supreme court made a determination
on the injunction but we can talk about
the law another time but let me say this
that we are complying with the court's
order we do have an obligation to
implement
the migrant protection protocols
and we are negotiating with mexico
because those protocols require a
bilateral agreement and so we are
negotiating with mexico as we are
required to do under the court's order
mr secretary thank you thanks for your
time thanks for taking time out during
these very busy days to speak with us
sir thank you so much for having me